today we're going to talk about light
field cameras okay which are a bit of a
physics nightmare but make for some
really cool images I was a bit of amused
online because I looked at dozens of
articles on how it works and none of
them told me the summary is it's a magic
box and then you can be focused image
okay in actual fact it's fairly
intuitive once you understand it but
it's mathematically fairly complicated
we're going to skip past most of the
mass because you don't need to know that
if you're implementing it and we're
going to talk about basically optically
how does it work
this camera is developed by a company
called alight row let me just try and
focus on that right and I'm focused now
on it yeah you focused on it okay but if
I move it you're not it's a problem okay
so what a light-filled camera does is
let you focus kind of magically after
you've taken a picture so we take a
picture you don't really care about
focusing this doesn't have a focus knob
on it or any kind of autofocus it does
this by essentially capturing much more
information on the light entering the
scene but a normal camera okay now this
is a light row which is a brand name
okay for a consumer plenoptic or light
field camera okay there are other
companies around rate fixes one that do
more industrial level light field
cameras which we'll talk about a little
bit okay I'm holding up a light row
mainly because I own a light row and or
I should say the school loans alight row
and we can perhaps take a test image and
I can show you kind of sort of things
you can do with a light row image but
you can't do with a normal image so
before we go into that just talk me
through this because it doesn't look
quite like any normal camera no all you
do with this is you point it at
something so I'll take this it there's
the lens right you point it at something
and you press go and it takes a picture
okay there we go
I mean yes to an extent you have to
worry about what you're taking a picture
of because it's still photography right
but later on are worried about what do I
want in the foreground what do I want in
the background or do I actually want to
change them and have it interactive or
maybe on a sort of move the angle
slightly of the image you point it at
something you take a picture and then
you're done okay and any kind of other
effects like depth of field and things
you worry about later on the computer
okay so perhaps we should take a test
image and we'll see what it looks like
okay so I'm going to move over here for
a minute okay and then we'll see what
that looks like on the laptop okay so we
plug this in
very straightforward we run the software
this isn't a normal image
like there's a lot more information that
we'll talk about in a minute but it
means that you have to process them
before you can look at them properly
okay what that does is essentially
reconstruct a proper image based on all
the information but it's got so if we
click on an image now we can see we've
got a picture view and I can click on
different parts of this image and focus
on it I've clicked on your head and
you're in focus and I click on the
camera and that's in focus or on the
back back wall and that's sort of more
in focus and essentially what we're
doing here is refocusing after the image
has been taken which is good because I'm
not very good at focusing images and so
I can just click and point-and-click now
they're obviously stipulations the image
isn't hugely high resolution and if you
take an image that's just bad it's not
going to be saved by the fact that I can
tweak it post-processing okay but it's
quite a cool feature another nice
feature is that we can do a kind of
perspective shift an image that shows us
really well as this picture of a
keyboard that we took so in this
keyboard we can still focus on the
background or the foreground just like
we could before but we can also click
and move the image around and you can
see that there's a sort of power laxing
going on the background is moving more
than a foreground so we're actually
changing a viewpoint the camera the
photograph has been taken from which is
kind of unintuitive because there's only
one lens how's that done so the first
thing to do is talk about how a regular
camera works with a lens and that will
give you some idea of what the
differences between this and and this
light ray so we're talking about a scene
on the left and like camera on the right
hand side and a really simple model for
my camera now we won't run on the fact
that lenses usually have more cool
elements in them than that and we'll
pretend this is my nice perfect lens
that bend light just I want okay and
this is my CTD so that's the sensor or
the chip in the camera and if anyone
wants to see more about those we can go
and look and look at that in the video
on the bio filter light enters our scene
from this direction through the lens and
then hits the back of a sensor we won't
worry about which orientation the images
on obviously it's upside down but that's
obviously changed in post-processing so
if we use our nice red pen for our light
a light ray comes in here from this
object here it hits the lens and then
it's been to a certain amount based on
the shape of the lens and then comes and
hits another point on the sensor now
what's really interesting is that there
isn't just a single ray of light coming
from say your face when I take a picture
of you straight into the camera there
are millions millions of
photons buy all with all different
directions so what if that happens is if
this is a part of some feature but I'm
looking at light comes in all different
directions this direction this direction
this direction and all gets bent around
and hits a CCD at the exact right point
and then we have a lovely image fits in
focus fortunate ever quite that simple
is it especially with my photography so
imagine that instead we've either moved
our lens or objects moved okay so now
I'm objected here okay slightly in front
of where it was before the lens blends
are like the same amount as it did
before okay it's not got better suddenly
so our light comes out like this and it
comes together behind the CCD so that's
what happens when you've got out of
focus shots so that that effectively the
fact that it's not converged on a point
is a blur yeah and a very succinctly
lens blur so the light from this object
has basically been split over all this
part of the sensor ideal in some kind of
nice photography not ideal if that's
what you're taking a picture of and the
same is true of an object that's too far
away the focal point will come in here
and be in front of the CCD and then will
spread back out again and just the same
as this will be spread over some area of
a sensor so that's what this light
webcam will try to do away with another
interesting feature if we just draw
another one this CCD element just adds
up all the light rays it hit it over a
certain period of time and that's what
color it becomes so this area of the
Rays could be blue and if the area could
be red and then when you get to here
it's a mixture of blue and red now that
might not be useful but that's the whole
point of how a camera works okay it
centrally sums up a lot of light rays on
a certain area why is that important
well imagine if we knew the differences
between these light rays in these light
rays we can start to perhaps get a feel
about what's going on in the scene it
needs a bit more detail okay so we've
lost this orientation information we
don't know what this particular way came
from this angle and this particular way
came from this angle we know as they
both hit here
the end okay that's gone we're never
getting that back well life field camera
does is capture the orientation as well
as the color of the race so a life up
camera is really sort of an extension of
a normal camera okay so we have our main
lens just like before and we have our
sensor just like before but what we also
have is a micro lens array an array of
tiny lenses in a grid for
Meishan but sit just in front of our ccd
okay so I'll draw them in now these are
much bigger than they would be in real
life as thousands of these it's best to
think of it perhaps the pixel resolution
or image is now these micro lenses light
comes in from an object and it converges
on one of these micro lenses just like
it would converge on a pixel we're
assuming it's in focus so let's say this
one but now this one is not actually
capturing the picture so these light
rays travel through the lens and spread
back out again underneath onto the CCD
okay so each section of CCD is
responsible for capturing all the
different light waves coming in for that
micro lens and you can see that the ones
over this side of each lens are coming
from this direction and the ones over
this side administration so we've
preserved our orientation information
why we do that will make some sense
hopefully in a minute focus wise it's
all calibrated so that the main lens and
these micro lenses match up so but
essentially this is what happens the
points in the world for the most part
come to being focus on these micro
lenses now that we've got all of these
rays what do we do we've just talked
about that being a blur but presumably
that's it's not a blur is it no if you
had just an image this out-of-focus
right then what you're getting is you're
getting these wave spread over bits at
the CCD okay but you also getting the
Rays of every other object spread over
the CCD and they all learn up and become
a really blurry image okay in this it's
much more controlled because only the
Rays from a certain point are projecting
into certain areas under our micro
lenses so one of the nice things
optically about how this works and might
help you understand it is that if we
pick an individual pixel under a
microphone lens all the light going
through that pixel comes from the same
place on the main lens okay so it comes
down here and it bends and it comes from
this point here okay this is called with
sub aperture so this pixel only ever
sees light entering at that point okay
and this pixel over the other side only
sees light entering from this point so
they essentially get different views of
the scene one from the left of a camera
one from the right of a camera so you
can start to think okay so we've got two
views maybe we can start to do some kind
of depth reasoning about this just like
we do with our binocular stereo another
interesting feature is every ray that
passes through this sub aperture hits
over different micro lenses and always
ends up on the same corresponding pixel
underneath each micro lens
so if we pick pixel five underneath
every micro lens it's going to
reconstruct the entire image as seen
from this point on the camera or in a
different pixel this point on the camera
what we've essentially done is not just
obtained orientation we've also obtained
loads of tiny little images that view
the scene from all over the main lens
another way to look at it is that these
micro lenses are just tiny cameras
taking a picture of the back of a main
lens okay and of course are going to
have a different view because somewhere
over on the left and some are over on
the right okay so that might be another
way of looking at it so what do we do
with this
well it's mathematically fairly
complicated but hopefully intuitively
not too bad let's imagine that we want
to do our parallax shift okay because
that's a nice easy one okay we want to
view the image from the left and then we
want to pan over and view it slightly
from the right and of course you saw
from the from the software but the
parallax isn't huge we're talking a
small amount and that's because the
width of the main lens is not huge if we
look at these this CCD from the back
okay
and we look at two neighboring micro
lens rays if we're both going to get
pictures that look a bit like this
so essentially pictures of this lens
from slightly different positions and
some stuff in the scene will be
happening in these pixels now just like
I said that all the Rays going through a
certain pixel go through a certain stuff
aperture and crucially all the way
through this sub aperture hit the
equivalent pixels that's true if we take
this pixel from this micro lens and the
same pixel in this micro lens and the
same pixel my next micro lens for every
micro lens we get a tiny image from the
left-hand side of the lens and if we do
the same thing but with these pixels on
the right we get the same for the
right-hand side of a lens oh it might be
left and right you know optics okay so
we can get a power lock shift by
basically reconstruct your image by
taking one pixel from each of a micro
lenses perhaps the most obvious and
perhaps most sort of magical feature of
the pelagic camera is refocusing so
refocusing is essentially moving the CCD
relative to the main lens I mean
actually you move the main lens optics
in normal camera but we're not going to
do that so if we fix our main lens here
and we pretend that there's a nice new
sensor in here okay this object is now
going to be out of focus this red object
but other objects might become in focus
normally how a regular camera works if
we are taking this image of this level
of focus we wouldn't be able to
reconstruct these rays because we don't
have them
we have these raised because we've
gotten plan optic camera so we can work
out which of these Rays we need to
sample from to reconstruct what this
image would look like if the CCD had
been here instead of here so essentially
a mathematical summation of lots of
different pixels in these micro lenses
so that's basically how a larger camera
works the micro lens is obviously fixed
in front of a CCD so this camera will
always operate in this fashion the Lytro
itself is is proprietary software in a
proprietary format so you plug your
camera in you use larger software to
extract it okay but what you're going to
get out is essentially a kind of
animatable
image that you can move about and change
your focus and twiddle with in really
cool ways and then if you publish them
online they call them living pictures
they can move about and you can sort of
draw focus of the viewer to interesting
parts of image by kind of zooming in or
by bringing them into focus suddenly so
it's quite nifty
it's like a pair of those 3d glasses
that you use where one sides red and one
sides blue but you've also got green
ones and you've got them in a grid
arrangement in front of your your
camera's eye